ton
on ne lit plus guère prosper-mérimée ce
contemporain de victor hugo et des
romantiques qui fut aussi l'ami de
stendhal et de l'impératrice eugénie et
qui mena sous le second empire
une brillante carrière de haut
fonctionnaire comme inspecteur des
monuments historiques de mérimée la
nouvelle collection des classiques
d'aujourd'hui au livre de poche réédite
une très brève nouvelle la vénus d'ille
c'est que notre homme est un maître
nouvelliste auteur aussi de colomb à de
mateo falcone et de carmen acquis bizet
devait donner la notoriété que l'on sait
écrivain concis au style limpide mairie
mais publie la vénus d'ille en 1837
c'est un conte fantastique qui se
déroule dans les pyrénées il est une
petite ville guère éloigné de perpignan
une statue de vénus antique a été
extraite des profondeurs de la terre
à la grande surprise du pétulant
monsieur de père en rade
l'érudit local tout énervé par cette
découverte
or du visage parfait de l'objet se
dégage écrit meriem et une ironie
infernal souligné encore par
l'inscription gravée sur le socle cave
et âme en peine prends garde à celui qui
t'aime on va s'en rendre compte
la vénus d'ille et comme carmen une
beauté fatale